Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishist L.P. Hartley famously said, the past is a foreign country. They do things differently there. But do they? Today on our episode of The Rest Is History, we want to look at the very recent past prompted by the return to netflix of the crown but before we come to that uh and i know dominic you'll be straining at the least about this because uh
感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。想要获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听、剧集抢先看以及加入我们备受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishist 正如L·P·哈特利的名言所说，过去是一个异国，他们在那里行事方式不同。但真的如此吗？今天在我们的《The Rest Is History》节目中，受网飞《王冠》回归的启发，我们想要回顾一下非常近的过去，但在我们谈到这一点之前——我知道多米尼克，你对此肯定急不可耐，因为……
recent british history is very much your subject isn't it so you're gonna have you're gonna have lots to say um i just wanted to say uh to thank everybody who's uh who's listening for um having helped us get off to such a great start it's's fantastic. We were a bit nervous about launching this, but we're thrilled that so many of you are out there, are listening and emailing in and tweeting and contributing. And please do keep that going. Yeah, it's quite a surprise, isn't it, Tom? I was expecting a torrents of abuse.
近代英国历史很大程度上正是你的专业领域，不是吗？所以你肯定有很多话要说。我只是想说，感谢所有收听节目的听众，感谢你们帮助我们取得了如此棒的开端，这太棒了。我们对推出这个节目其实有点紧张，但看到有这么多人在收听、发邮件、发推特并积极互动，我们感到非常兴奋。请大家继续保持。是的，这真是个惊喜，对吧，汤姆？我本来还以为会遭到如潮的恶评。
Well, I mean, I obviously get torrents of abuse naturally on a sort of daily basis anyway. So this is a nice break for me to well i was i was kind of expect i was kind of expecting tumbleweed to be honest so um so neither abuse nor tumbleweed so do please um keep uh you know keep letting us know what you think um should we should we read out some tweets that'd be a very good idea yeah should we engage with the with the great british public yes we had somebody, Alex Burson, he wrote, thanks for doing it. The rest of history is great.
嗯，我的意思是，我自然而然地每天都会收到如潮的恶评，所以对我来说，这算是一个不错的喘息机会。好吧，说实话，我其实有点在等连滚草（一片寂静）的出现。所以，既没有恶评也没有连滚草，请大家务必继续让我们知道你们的想法。我们是不是该读几条推特？这主意真不错。是的，我们要不要和伟大的英国公众互动一下？是的，我们有一位听众叫亚历克斯·伯森，他写道：谢谢你们做这个节目。《The Rest Is History》太棒了。
For your amusement, Stephen the Great of Moldova was sanctified by the Orthodox Church in the 1990s and is now Stephen the Great and saint. He had four wives, as saint should, and was known to be quick to spill blood, but he built churches and defended Christianity. He was quite great. It's just that the saint is both a late addition
为了博君一笑，摩尔达维亚的斯特凡大帝在20世纪90年代被东正教封圣，现在被称为“斯特凡大帝兼圣徒”。他有四个妻子（正如圣徒所应当的那样），以好杀戮闻名，但他建造了教堂并捍卫了基督教。他确实很伟大。只是“圣徒”这个身份既是一个后来的追加，
and amusing in the context of episode one. So there you go. Yeah, I mean, being a saint and great, I mean, that's a square in the circle, isn't it? Yeah, I mean, he did a bit of everything, didn't he? Yeah. Polymath. We also have a message from Andrew Walker.
而且在第一集的语境下显得很滑稽。所以，就是这样。是的，我的意思是，既是圣徒又是伟人，这简直是个不可能完成的任务，对吧？对，我的意思是，他什么都做了一点，不是吗？对。全才。我们还收到了安德鲁·沃克的留言。
He's been wondering about academic reassessment of Nero. Oh, good, good. Academic reassessment of Nero. That's very much my thing. This person exists. He's not you. Oh, good, good. Academic reassessment of Nero. That's very much my thing. This is definitely, this person exists. He's not you under a false name, Tom. My sock puppet.
他一直在思考学术界对尼禄的重新评估。哦，太好了，太好了。学术界对尼禄的重新评估。这完全是我的拿手好戏。这个人是存在的。他可不是你。哦，太好了，太好了。学术界对尼禄的重新评估。这完全是我的拿手好戏。这绝对是，这个人是存在的。他不是你用假名假扮的，汤姆。我的提线木偶。
He's heard about it on another podcast, Boo Hiss. It amounts to, well, he was rather popular with the plebs. People after him invoked him to boost their appeal and his critics were fake news from the swamp. Yeah, I mean, basically, yeah, can't disagree with that. to boost their appeal and his critics were fake news from the swamp yeah i mean basically yeah can't disagree with that um and uh and then we got lovely a lovely comment from um emma salisbury um i'm listening to this right now it's rather nostalgically like being at a friendly dinner party with fellow historians even though tom holland and dominic sandbrook can't hear me
他是在另一个播客里听到这个说法的，嘘——倒彩。这大致相当于，嗯，他在平民中相当受欢迎。他之后的人利用他来提升自己的人气，而他的批评者则是来自泥潭的假新闻。是的，我的意思是，基本上，是的，对此无法反驳。用来提升他们的人气，而他的批评者则是来自泥潭的假新闻，是的，基本上，是的，对此无法反驳。嗯，然后我们收到了埃玛·索尔兹伯里的一条非常可爱的评论：我现在正在听这个，这种感觉非常有怀旧感，就像和志同道合的历史学家朋友们坐在一起参加一个友好的晚宴，尽管汤姆·霍兰和多米尼克·桑德布鲁克听不到我
chiming in so that that speaks somebody who's clearly never been at a dinner party with historians. The mood of bitterness and rancour. Yes, well, bitterness and rancour is what we're all about. So anyway, you can, this dinner party, this friendly dinner party, do join in. You can chime in, tweet us, hashtag the rest is history. And also very excitingly, we've got an email address now. Rest is history pod at gmail.com. Rest is history pod at gmail.com. And I like that idea of the ultimate historical dinner party. I mean, I think that would be a good idea for a future episode. Say what kind of people from across the range of history who would make the ideal dinner party? Genghis Khan.
插话。所以这说明发这条信息的人显然从来没和历史学家一起吃过晚宴。那种充满痛苦和怨恨的气氛。是的，好吧，痛苦和怨恨正是我们的宗旨。总之，你可以，这个晚宴，这个友好的晚宴，欢迎加入。你可以插话，给我们发推特，带话题#the rest is history。另外非常令人兴奋的是，我们现在有了一个电子邮箱地址。restishistorypod@gmail.com。restishistorypod@gmail.com。我挺喜欢终极历史晚宴这个主意的。我觉得这可以作为未来某一期节目的好题材。说说看，邀请历史上哪些各行各业的人来才能组成理想的晚宴阵容？成吉思汗。
No, he'd be terrible. He'd chop your head off and drink out of your skull. That's a terrible idea. Anyway, we're not going to get onto that. Let's get onto The Crown. Yes, let's. Because I'm guessing you have, do you have views on this? Have you seen The Crown? As you well know, Tom, I have never seen The Crown. I have not seen so much as a minute of The Crown. Why would I? I mean, I spend, you The Crown. I have not seen so much as a minute of The Crown. Why would I? I mean, I spend, you know, my working day thinking about Harold Wilson or whatever.
不，他太糟糕了。他会砍掉你的头，然后用你的头骨喝酒。这主意太糟了。不管怎样，我们不聊这个了。我们来聊聊《王冠》。好的，聊聊吧。因为我猜你对此有看法，你看过《王冠》吗？正如你很清楚的，汤姆，我从来没看过《王冠》。我连《王冠》的一分钟都没看。我为什么要看？我的意思是，我花……《王冠》。我连《王冠》的一分钟都没看。我为什么要看？我的意思是，我花，你知道的，把工作日的时间都用来思考哈罗德·威尔逊或者别的事情上。
And Dominic, has the fact that you have never seen The Crown, has it prevented you from writing about it? No, obviously not. I mean, that would be anathema to all I stand for. Have you just written an enormous spread about the 80s to coincide with the new series of The Crown set in the 80s? No, I haven't, but I have given a long interview to BBC History magazine about it, but they know I haven't seen it. So they describe it to me over the phone. They tell me what happens and I tell them what I think of it. I think it
多米尼克，你从来没看过《王冠》这件事，有没有妨碍你写关于它的文章？不，当然没有。我的意思是，那将与我所坚信的一切背道而驰。你是不是刚刚写了一篇关于80年代的长篇大论，来配合以80年代为背景的新一季《王冠》的上映？不，我没有，但我为此接受了《BBC历史》杂志的长篇采访，但他们知道我没看过。所以他们在电话里向我描述。他们告诉我发生了什么，然后我告诉他们我对这件事的看法。我觉得这样
works very well. And just to make it clear to the listeners, you've written a highly acclaimed series of books about modern British history that that exactly cover the the span of the decades that yeah exactly cover and your most recent book was um it was what it was kind of like 7 000 page volume about three the first three years of the thatcher government so from 79 to 82. So bang in the middle of that is the summer of 1981, which of course has the Royal Wedding. Yeah. Well, the Royal Wedding is obviously a big deal for the Crown, isn't it? Diana and all that.
效果非常好。为了向听众澄清一下，你写过一套备受赞誉的关于现代英国历史的书籍，正好涵盖了那些年代的时间跨度，对，正好涵盖了，而你最近的一本书是……它是一本大约7000页的厚巨著，写的是撒切尔政府的前三年，也就是从1979年到1982年。所以正处在其中的核心位置，就是1981年的夏天，当然，那年有皇家婚礼。是的。好吧，皇家婚礼对《王冠》来说显然是一件大事，对吧？黛安娜和诸如此类的事情。
Carry on. And it's a bigger deal for the Crown than it is for your book. It would be fair to say. It is mentioned in my book. I mean, there is a whole section about the Royal Wedding, but I'm kind of more, I mean, to be fair to say. Well, it is mentioned in my book. I mean, there is a whole section about the royal wedding, but I'm kind of more, I mean, to be honest with you, Tom, cakes, dresses, you know, page boys, that sort of stuff fills me with utter gloom and misery. So when I talked about it in my book, it was more, what did people make of
继续。这对于《王冠》来说，比对你的书更重要。这样说算公允吧。我的书中确实提到了这一点。我的意思是，书中有一个整节专门讲皇家婚礼，但我其实更……我的意思是，要公平地说。好吧，我的书中确实提到了这一点。我的意思是，有一个整节是关于皇家婚礼的，但我其实更……我的意思是，说实话，汤姆，蛋糕、礼服、伴童，诸如此类的事情让我感到无比的沮丧和痛苦。所以当我在书中谈到这一点时，我更多的是在探讨：人们对它有什么看法？
it? What was the meaning of it um and also actually putting it against the background of all this other stuff which is so interesting which is going on in 81 so the riots the recession the cricket of course which we'll come to later um this sort of tumultuous year you know 1981 is one of those years i suppose a little bit like sort of 1968 or something that has a meaning beyond... Or 2020, perhaps. Or 2020, exactly. I think you can make a reasonable case that 1981 was the grimmest year in our lifetimes. And actually grimmer than 2020, because 2020 is worldwide, whereas 1981 was just, you know, it was Britain that was uniquely in a terrible mess.
它的意义是什么？而且，实际上把它放在所有其他同样非常有趣的背景下进行对比——这些事情都发生在81年，比如骚乱、经济衰退，当然还有板球（我们稍后会谈到板球）——这是一个动荡的年份，你知道，1981年是那种让人觉得有点像1968年左右、具有超越……的意义的年份。或者也许是2020年。或者2020年，完全正确。我认为你可以提出一个合理的论点，即1981年是我们有生以来最严峻的一年。实际上比2020年还要严峻，因为2020年是全球性的，而1981年只是，你知道的，只有英国陷入了独特的糟糕困境中。
So, I mean, the key thing about the Royal Wedding, everyone said it was like a fairy tale. And the irony about that is partly that the backdrop is this Britain in a state of complete turmoil, unemployment, rioting, and so on. But also the fact, of course, that the marriage was going to go terribly wrong. And I just wondered, before we get on to
所以，关于皇家婚礼的关键点是，每个人都说它就像童话一样。其中的讽刺之处部分在于，其背景是处于彻底动荡、失业、骚乱等状态中的英国。但当然还有这样一个事实，即这段婚姻最终会走向彻底的糟糕。我只是在想，在我们探讨
the kind of historical context for 1981 provides what's your view as a historian of modern britain about the way in which the story of the royal family has kind of become like the matter of britain that you know like the matter of britain in the middle ages was the story of king arthur that in a way for lots of people the story of king arthur was was more real you know they knew more about that than they knew anything about you know what was actually happening in medieval england and there's a kind of slight sense with you know that globally what people know about british history is kind of you know and the story of diana in particular it's kind of like the modern matter of britain people know about the story of diana it's become this mythic story. Does that have any historical significance?
1981年所提供的历史背景之前，作为一名现代英国历史学家，你对王室故事如何演变成类似于“不列颠传说”（Matter of Britain）这种现象有什么看法？就像中世纪的“不列颠传说”是亚瑟王的故事一样，在某种程度上，对许多人来说，亚瑟王的故事更加真实（你知道，他们对那个故事的了解，甚至超过了他们对中世纪英格兰实际发生的事情的了解），而且在全球范围内，人们对英国历史的了解——尤其是黛安娜的故事——也有着类似的感觉，它就像是现代的“不列颠传说”，人们了解黛安娜的故事，它已经变成了一个神话般的故事。这有什么历史意义吗？
I mean, what does that say about Britain's role in the world? OK, so I think that's true of Diana, right? I think that's true that you can take the story of Diana and you can say, but you can also tease out sort of historical meanings about, you know, the sentimentalisation of British culture. Diana obviously played a big part in the sort of a new kind of, or a renewed kind of emotionalism in Britain's sort of public life, you know, sort of embracing aid sufferers and so on, you know, doing things that the monarchy or the public figures wouldn't have done 10 or 20 years earlier. So's sort of she is an important figure in that context
我的意思是，这说明了英国在世界上的角色是什么？好吧，我认为这对于黛安娜来说是真的，对吧？我认为你可以拿黛安娜的故事来说明这一点，但你也可以梳理出一些历史意义，比如英国文化的感伤化。黛安娜显然在英国公共生活中那种新的、或者说复兴的情感主义中扮演了重要角色，比如拥抱艾滋病患者等等，做一些王室或公众人物在十年前或二十年前不会做的事情。所以在这种背景下，她显然是一个重要人物。
obviously but the royal family more generally i'm not so sure so i agree with you there are things that are that people care more about than the usual sort of political events sport is actually a really good example of that so a lot of people when they make sense of the recent past they don't think about general elections and governments. They think about World Cups and how their team got on and all that kind of thing. And music, again, you ask anybody about their youth or if they grew up in the 60s or the 70s, it's often music that they turn to as their cultural references.
但更广泛地看王室，我可就不那么确定了。所以我同意你的看法，有些事情比通常的政治事件更受人们关注。体育其实就是一个很好的例子。因此，许多人在理解近代历史时，他们想到的不是大选和政府，而是世界杯以及他们支持的球队表现如何之类的事情。还有音乐，同样地，你问任何人关于他们的青春期，或者他们是否在60年代或70年代长大，他们往往会把音乐作为他们的文化参考。
And they'll say, well, the 60s ended when the Beatles broke up or the 70s ended when Sid V broke up or, you know, the 70s ended when, you know, Sid Vicious died or whatever it might be. People will look on those things as the sort of chronological structuring, I guess, for the recent past. So I'm not so sure that the monarchy is the key one that I would go for. I mean, maybe it's because I don't really care
他们会说，嗯，60年代在披头士解散时结束了，或者70年代在席德·维瑟斯（Sid Vicious）去世时结束了，诸如此类。人们会将这些事情视为近代历史的某种时间结构，我猜是这样的。所以我不太确信君主制是我会选择的关键点。我的意思是，也许是因为我其实并不那么关心
that much about the sort of royal story. It's interesting you talk about music because actually the thing for me that's interesting about the 80s is that it's when I was a teenager so I was becoming kind of aware of politics. I remember there was not the Nine O'Clock News, which was a kind of satire show, and they did not the royal wedding. And it was kind of like the first disrespectful treatment of the royal family that I'd come across.
皇室的故事。有趣的是你谈到了音乐，因为对我来说，关于80年代有趣的事情实际上是那正是我当青少年的时期，所以我开始对政治有了一点意识。我记得当时有一个叫《九点钟新闻》（Not the Nine O'Clock News）的节目，这是一个讽刺类节目，他们做了一个“非官方皇家婚礼”（Not the Royal Wedding）。这算是我接触到的对王室的第一种不敬的处理方式。
And I remember, you know, I was kind of 13, thought it was great. But what I also remember is that there was a series on, I think on Radio 1 at the time, it's called 25 Years of Rock, and it ran from 1955 to 1979. And it kind of set current affairs to a soundtrack of the music of that particular year. And it stopped in 79. It never went on into 1980, 1981 and so on. I was hugely disappointed about that. But what I was thinking now when you were talking about music and the tumultuous events of 81 is the way in which, you know, the really scarring experience was mass unemployment, inner city deprivation.
我记得，你知道的，我当时大概13岁，觉得这太棒了。但我也记得当时BBC一台（Radio 1）正在播出一个系列节目，叫做《摇滚25年》（25 Years of Rock），时间跨度从1955年到1979年。它将时事与特定年份的音乐原声结合在一起。但它在79年停播了，没有延伸到1980年、1981年等等。我对此感到非常失望。但当我刚才听你谈论音乐和81年的动荡事件时，我想到了那种真正给人留下创伤的经历，那就是大规模失业和内城贫困。
And the soundtrack to that you always get is Ghost Town. And that's kind of like, you know, the moment you hear that, that is early 80s Thatcherism. It just kind of conjures it up, doesn't it? Yeah, it does. I mean, I did a TV documentary about the 80s, and I can't remember if you used Ghost Town or not, but when we were doing it, we kind of went through and we said,
而与之相伴的音乐背景音总是《鬼镇》（Ghost Town）。这就好比，你知道的，只要你一听到那个旋律，那就是80年代初的撒切尔主义。它一下子就把那种氛围勾勒出来了，对吧？是的，确实如此。我的意思是，我曾制作过一部关于80年代的电视纪录片，我记不清我们在片子里有没有用《Ghost Town》了，但当我们制作时，我们曾讨论过，
everybody expects that when we do the miners' strike, by law, by sort of UN-mandated law, you have to have two tribes, don't you? Yes, yes. So the footage is the Battle of Orgreave and two tribes is playing. And we sort of said, we need to steer clear of this as much as we can, although I think we probably did use Ghost Town.
每个人都预料到，当我们讲到矿工罢工时，根据某种不成文的、联合国授权般的法律，你必须播放《Two Tribes》，对吧？是的，是的。所以画面是奥格里夫之战（Battle of Orgreave），同时播放着《Two Tribes》。我们当时就说，我们需要尽可能避开这个，虽然我想我们最后可能还是用了《Ghost Town》。
So you're right, but that's true of older periods too, right? When you're doing mid-Victorian Britain, you always use Dickens. Yeah, but you're talking about music. Music is a kind of lingua franca, if you like. It's everybody understands what it means. Everybody has the same associations and so on. So I don't think it's actually that different from using literary sources from earlier periods to illustrate, you know, to sort of connote a particular time, a particular atmosphere, don't you think? of provided a soundtrack um that everyone remembers and recognizes um simply because the music industry has has grown so much and the ability of people to consume it has has grown exponentially and kind
所以你是对的，但这对于更早的时期也同样适用，对吧？当你研究维多利亚时代中期的英国时，你总是会引用狄更斯。是的，但你在谈论音乐。音乐是一种通用语，如果你愿意这么说的话。每个人都懂它意味着什么，每个人都有相同的联想等等。所以我不认为这实际上与使用早期时期的文学作品来阐释、来传达特定时代、特定氛围有什么不同，你不觉得吗？提供了一个每个人都记得并能认出的原声带，仅仅是因为音乐产业已经发展得如此庞大，人们消费音乐的能力呈指数级增长，
of for that reason it it does kind of conjure up images so so you know rather like the royal family um britain has has been very central to the music industry so i would say that the story of the beatles is a kind of parallel to the story of Diana, that it's a kind of almost mythic tale that everyone kind of instinctively knows. And likewise, the story of music, the story of the royal family, the story of sport,
也正因如此，它确实能够唤起人们的种种意象。所以，你知道的，就像王室一样，英国一直是音乐产业的核心。所以我想说，披头士乐队的故事某种程度上与黛安娜的故事平行，它是一个几乎每个人都本能地知道的近乎神话般的故事。同样，音乐的故事、王室的故事、体育的故事，
all of this is a kind of part of the fabric of recent history. And I just wonder, you know, is it part of that because that's what we remember, that's what we experienced most vividly, or is it more significant than that? Ah, that's a good question. Is it more significant than that?
所有这一切都是近代历史结构的一部分。我只是在想，你知道的，这之所以成为一部分，是因为那是我们所记忆的、是我们经历得最生动的，还是说它具有更重大的意义？啊，这是个好问题。它比那更具重大意义吗？
I think there is a sort of a story about Britain's decline on the world stage and the way we sell ourselves to the world. We sell ourselves through pop culture now in a way that we wouldn't have done you know in let's say the 19th century so if you'd said to somebody in 19th century britain well the most important thing about this given moment is our tremendously rich tradition of musical and we will be remembered for our splendid novels um people would have laughed at you they'd have said that's not important at all whereas now
我认为这里有一个关于英国在世界舞台上衰落的故事，以及我们向世界兜售自己的方式的故事。我们现在通过流行文化向世界兜售自己，这在，比如说，19世纪是不会做到的。所以，如果你对19世纪的英国人说，“嗯，此时此刻最重要的事情是我们极其丰富的音乐传统，我们将因我们精彩的小说而被铭记”，人们会嘲笑你的。他们会说那一点都不重要，然而现在，
i think we do think these things are important and they are redolent of Britishness. So they're what we think matters. So when Danny Boyle did his 2012 Olympics opening ceremony, a lot of it was about Britain's tradition of music and storytelling and all the rest of it. That these things were kind of intrinsic to Britishness. So it's not surprising that when we tell the story
我认为我们确实认为这些事情很重要，它们充满了英国特色。所以这些正是我们认为要紧的事情。因此，当丹尼·博伊尔（Danny Boyle）举办2012年伦敦奥运会开幕式时，其中很大一部分内容都关于英国的音乐传统、讲故事传统以及所有这些，这些东西是英国特性的内在组成部分。所以，当我们讲述
of the very recent past, it's those things that we look to because actually those things seem more sort of vital than you know the story of the rise and fall of Ted Heath's government which most people couldn't give a damn about and and yet I suppose one of the one of the things about um about the early 80s is actually that the politics is really kind of viscerally in your face in a way that perhaps it hadn't been at any other period. I mean, maybe in the, I don't know, in the Heath government with the three-day weekend. No, far more than in the Heath government. I think politics in the 80s is such a great narrative story. And the divisions in Britain in 81, between North and South, between country and inner city?
非常近期的过去的histoire时，我们会关注这些事情也就不足为奇了，因为实际上这些事情似乎比泰德·希思（Ted Heath）政府兴衰的故事要重要得多——大多数人根本不在乎这个。然而我想，关于80年代初的一点，实际上政治是以一种非常直观、扑面而来的方式呈现的，这种程度可能是以往任何时期都没有过的。我的意思是，也许在，我不知道，在希思政府执政期间实行每周三天工作制的时候？不，比希思政府时期强烈得多。我认为80年代的政治是一个非常棒的故事题材。81年英国的分裂：南北分裂，乡村与内城的对立？
I mean, give a sense of how divided the country was. I think enormously divided. And, you know, for people who don't, for younger listeners who don't remember it, Margaret Thatcher had come in in 79 after sort of perceived years of decline. And she basically said she was going to administer this shock therapy, this sort of harsh medicine that would turn Britain around. And after two years, everything seemed to have got incalculably worse.
这给人们带来了一种国家分裂得有多严重的感觉。我认为分裂得极其严重。而且，对于那些不记得这一点的年轻听众来说，玛格丽特·撒切尔在经历了人们认为多年的衰落之后，于79年上台。她基本上宣布她将实施这种休克疗法，这种严厉的药方来扭转英国的局面。但在两年后，一切似乎都变得无可估量地更加糟糕。
Britain was in recession. We had unemployment at more than heading towards 4 million, effectively. Young people in particular couldn't get jobs. You had riots, first of of all in brixton in april and then spreading around the country in the summer you had massive um unrest massive um rioting in northern ireland where you had the hunger strikes of republican prisoners in the maize prison you had this sort of sense that the whole country was coming unglued and that almost uniquely in western europe you know here was this sort of former imperial power this major industrial
英国陷入了经济衰退。失业人数超过并正朝着400万大关迈进。特别是年轻人找不到工作。先是在4月发生了布里克斯顿骚乱，接着在夏天蔓延到全国各地。北爱尔兰也爆发了大规模的动乱和骚乱，当时梅兹监狱（Maze Prison）的共和党囚犯正在进行绝食抗议。整个国家给人的感觉是正在四分五裂，而且几乎是西欧独一无二地，这里——这个前帝国强权、主要的工业国——正在分崩离析，人们觉得，
nation that was just coming apart and people were sort of um that it was politically tearing itself apart i suppose so the government was the most unpopular government since records began the party the opposition party was incredibly bitterly divided. And there was this real sense of, which far greater, I think, than anything even over Brexit, of rancour and of sort of, you know, hostility. A real sense of the stakes being so high. And the stakes being the survival of the United Kingdom, you know, the prosperity of you
它在政治上正在把自己撕裂，我想是的。所以政府是自记录有史以来最不受欢迎的政府，反对党内部则陷入了极其痛苦的分裂。那种充满怨恨和敌意的感觉是真实存在的，我认为甚至比围绕英国脱欧的敌意还要强烈得多。人们真切地感觉到赌注是如此之高。而赌注就是联合王国的生存，是你和家人的繁荣，你知道的，这不是一种，这些不是象征性的问题。这些是极其直观的、关乎基本生计的问题。但你看，为什么近代历史对我来说很难驾驭，是因为我亲身经历过它。而我当时住在威尔特郡一个田园诗般的小村庄里。奇怪的是，我现在住在布里克斯顿。所以，你知道的，布里克斯顿曾是警察暴行和骚乱的中心。但是，你知道的，它对我来说就像远在百万英里之外。我关于81年夏天的记忆是，我母亲当时在住院。我父亲说，你知道的，他得照顾我，不知道还能做什么。
and your family, you know, this is not a sort of, these are not symbolic issues. These are incredibly visceral kind of bread and butter issues. But you see, the reason why recent history is, I find it kind of challenging to get a handle on is that I lived through it. And I was in a idyllic Wiltshire village. And oddly, I now live in Brixton. So, you know, and Brixton was kind of the epicentre of police brutality and the rioting. But, you know, it might as well have been a million miles from me. And what I remember about the summer of 81 is that my mother was in hospital. My father said, you know, he had to look after me, didn't know what else to do.
他说，好吧，我们来看一场板球对抗赛（Test match）吧。我对板球毫无兴趣，对体育也完全不感兴趣。那场对抗赛是海丁利（Headingley）板球赛，是有史以来最具变革性、最卓越的板球比赛之一。我知道那些对板球不感兴趣的人，尤其是那些听我们节目的非英国人，会对此感到有些困惑，但当时发生了那种令人惊叹的、童话般的逆转，
He said, well, let's watch a test match. And I had no interest in cricket, had no interest in sport at all. That test match was headingly and it was one of the most transformative, remarkable cricket matches of all time. I know that people who are not interested in cricket um certainly people who are who are not british listening to this will be slightly bewildered by it but but it it there was this astonishing kind of fairy tale reversal
英格兰原本处于绝境，但他们绝地反击，战胜了所有困难，击败了我们的老体育宿敌澳大利亚。而伊安·博瑟姆（Ian Botham）——一个如今主要因支持脱欧以及被鲍里斯·约翰逊提拔进入上议院而闻名的人物——成为了当时的英雄。这基本上改变了我的人生，因为它说服了我开始打板球，
where england had been down and out they came they they they triumphed against all the odds over australia our old uh sporting rival um And Ian Botham, a figure who is now famous chiefly for supporting Brexit and having been raised by Boris Johnson to the House of Lords, was the hero of the hour. And that essentially changed my life because it persuaded me to take up cricket,
板球自此成为我一生的挚爱之一。这就是我记忆中的1981年。所以从情感上、个人情感上来说，这就是我与那段历史的联系。我个人没有经历过骚乱、失业或诸如此类的事情。这让人觉得，正如人们常说的大事件那样，往往——这也是你在书中多次提到的观点——通常即使在可怕的事情正在发生时，
which has been one of the great loves of my life ever since. So that is how I remember 1981. So emotionally, emotionally personally that's that's my stake in it um i i had no personal experience of riots or unemployment or um or anything like that and it's kind of you know it makes you as what what's often said about the great events is that actually often and it's a point you make repeatedly throughout your books that often even when terrible things are happening,
绝大多数人其实都过得挺快乐的。是的，我想你是对的，汤姆。我的意思是，我觉得我们一会儿还得聊聊板球。顺便说一句，我真不敢相信你花了这期播客超过15分钟的时间才把话题转到伊安·博瑟姆身上。不过，我们先把博瑟姆放一边。我们待会儿再回过头来谈博瑟姆和板球，因为我认为板球其实确实具有真正的历史意义，我们可以在中场休息后深入探讨这一点。但在此之前，
most people are actually perfectly happy. Yeah, I think that's right, Tom. I mean, I think we should get on to the cricket in a second. I can't believe, by the way, it took you more than 15 minutes of this podcast to turn the conversation to Ian Botham. However, let's put Botham on one side. Let's come back to Botham and the cricket, because I think the cricket actually does have a proper historical historical significance which we can get into maybe after the break but before
是的，撰写当代史是一件非常奇怪的事情，因为当然，当你谈论这些时，你往往是在跟那些亲历过这个时代的人对话。这可不是你写《王朝》（Dynasty）、《卢比孔河》（Rubicon）或者你任何一本关于罗马人、希腊人或其他古人的书时会遇到的问题。我的意思是，他们不在现场来告诉你“你写错了”。当我去谈论我的书时，通常，你知道的，观众席上会有人点头赞同，但也会有其他人说：“哦，但60年代根本不是那样的。”或者“70年代，你知道的，根本不是那样。”我的意思是，这非常常见。
that um yes it's a very strange thing writing about contemporary history because of course often when you're talking about you're talking to people who live through it now that's not a problem that you really have when you're doing you know dynasty or or rubicon or any of your books on the romans the Greeks or whatever. I mean, they're not around to tell you you're wrong. When I go to talk about my books, often, you know, there'll be people nodding in the audience and then there'll be other people who say, oh, but the 60s wasn't like that at all. Or the 70s, you know, wasn't like that. I mean, that's very common.
我想，作为一名当代英国历史学家，你面临的一大挑战是，首先，你必须把自己的个人经历放在一边，但同时你还得兼顾你作为历史学家的工作——即强加你的规律并讲述你的故事——以及所有这些个人故事的复杂性。现在，这并不是你在作为古代历史学家时必须面对的事情，因为你没有那么多的史料。所以你不需要面对所有那些
And I guess one of the things with being a historian of contemporary Britain is, first of all, you have to put your own experience on one side, but also you have to juggle your own job as the historian, which is to impose your pattern and to tell your story, but also the complexity of all these kind of individual stories. Now, that's not really something that you have to confront as an ancient historian because you don't have many sources. So you don't have all the individual stories
缺乏代表性的普通人的个人故事。确实如此。确实如此。但我认为古代历史最迷人的地方之一，往往是你偶尔能瞥见人们过着他们的正常生活。没错。这些可能会被保存在墓碑上，可能会被保存在一首诗中。你知道，当内战在周围肆虐时，那种仅仅出去躺在田野里是什么感觉的蛛丝马迹。给我们举个例子。好吧，实际上，一直留在我脑海中的例子来自西塞罗的信件。
of all the people who are unrepresentative. That's true. That's true. But I think that one of the fascinating things about ancient history often is the glimpses you get occasionally of people leading their normal lives. Right. And it could be preserved on tombstones. It could be preserved in a poem. You know, the hints of what it's like to just go out and lie in a field while civil war is going on all around you. Give us an example. Well, actually, the example that always sticks in my mind comes from the letters of Cicero.
西塞罗当然深度参与了终结罗马共和国的剧变。但有一封信，他写到了他拥有的一座房子，上面出现了一条裂缝。你知道的，裂缝裂开了，他对此有点担心。你知道的，他该怎么修补它呢？这种想法是，即使在西塞罗深度参与的所有重大事件之中，他还在担心诸如DIY房屋修补之类的事情，
Cicero, of course, is intimately involved in the convulsions that ends the Roman Republic. But there's a letter in which he writes about a house he owns and it's got a crack. You know, a crack has opened up and he's a bit worried about this. You know, how's he going to repair it? And the idea that even amid all the events that Cicero was intimately involved in, he's worrying about kind of DIY repairs and things like that.
他该怎么办？我认为这表达了一个基本真理：生活还在继续。它在前行。有一首哈代（Hardy）的著名诗歌，不是吗？我想是他写的，里面写道……你知道吗，我们去休息一下吧，我去查查那首哈代写的诗，等我们回来时读给你听。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、
What's he going to do? I think that that's expressive of a fundamental truth that life carries on. It goes on. There's's kind of famous hardy poem isn't there which i think he wrote where he he says um do you know what let's let's go for a break and i'll look that um that hardy poem up and i'll read it to you when we come back i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews,
八卦猛料的固定栏目，在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及现场门票的抢先购买权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
欢迎回来，各位。我想汤姆有一首诗要送给我们。是的。这是我们在《The Rest Is History》中读的第一首诗。作者是哈代，题目是《在破坏国家之时》（In Time of the Breaking of Nations）。我来读第三节：“那边，一个少女和她的白色衣衫沙沙走过，战争的史册将黯淡成黑夜，他们的故事将消逝。”所以，你知道的，少男少女们依然会一起闲逛，尽管战争正在进行。但有趣的是第一节：“仅仅一个人在缓慢无声的步行中耕翻土块，牵着一匹老马，它一瘸一拐地打着磕睡，半睡半醒地前行。”所以哈代说，你知道的，人们会一直用马耕地，直到
Welcome back, everybody. I think Tom has a poem for us. I do. It's the first poem that we've had on The Rest Is History. It's by Hardy and it's called In Time of the Breaking of Nations. I'm going to read the third verse and it's Yonder a maid and her white come whispering by Wars annals will cloud into night air their story die so you know girls and boys will hang out with each other even though war's going on but interestingly the first verse only a man harrowing clods in a slow silent walk with an old horse that stumbles and nods half asleep as they stalk so hardly say you know that people will be plowing with horses till the
时间的尽头，而这显然是不真实的——所以不，事情确实会改变。这真是一个好例子。就像这样，刚才在休息前我还在想另一个例子——亚历山大大帝逝世当天唯一的史料来源，是由一位祭司保存的巴比伦占星日记，而上面记载的全是关于天气的事。所以，他大致写道：“国王驾崩了。与此同时，天气多云阴沉，血雨腥风。”他给予天气的关注比对事件本身的关注还要多。而这不正是我们大多数人思考政治和世界的方式吗？
end of time and that obviously isn't true so no things do change that's a good example like this at the time i was thinking one before um just before the break so the the only source from the day that alexander the great died was a babylonian astrological diary kept by a priest and he and it's all about the weather so um he sort of says the king died. Meanwhile, it was very cloudy and overcast and bloody. And he gives more attention to the weather than he does. And that's how most of us think about politics and the world, isn't it?
这算是一个戏说吧，对吧？据说在7月14日，路易十六的日记里写的是：“今天无事发生。”是的，可能确实是这样。我想也许那是关于狩猎记录什么的。我想这大概就是1700年以后所有国王记录重大事件时都会写的东西吧。不管怎样，回到——回到——回到81年。是的，你刚才想说的是，实际上1981年的板球赛具有巨大的历史意义，我很乐意听到对此的解释，因为如果能学到这一点就太好了。我认为它确实具有重大的历史意义。所以自60年代末以来，英国传出的消息一直相当糟糕。因此，尽管大多数人的生活条件
It's apocryphal, isn't it, that on the 14th of July, Louis XVI's diary read, nothing much happened. Yeah, I think that probably is. I think maybe it was the record of game or something i think that's what i think that's what all kings post about 1700 are supposed to have written about major events anyway back back back to back back to 81 um yes you you were going to say that actually the um that the the cricket in 1981 was of immense historical significance which i'd love to be reassured on that because that would be great to learn. I think it is of great historical significance. So the news for Britain since the late 60s had been pretty awful. So although most people are actually
比以往任何时候都要好，但头条新闻总是很糟糕。所以从1967年左右开始——也就是哈罗德·威尔逊将英镑贬值的时候——政府就陷入了不断的麻烦中，对英国来说一切都很糟糕。我认为在20世纪70年代末，你开始发现人们对好消息有一种渴望。所以这方面的第一个迹象，我认为是对SAS（英国特别空勤团）突袭伊朗大使馆行动的反应，他们在1980年从一场人质围困中解放了大使馆。当时小报等媒体做出了近乎歇斯底里的反应，认为英国又伟大了、我们是一流大国，诸如此类。然后你在1981年又两次看到了这种现象。一次是皇家婚礼，当时我们在排场和盛典上引领世界。另一次就是对赢得一场板球对抗赛做出的这种令人难以置信的歇斯底里
better off than they'd ever been, the sort of headlines were always bad. So from about 1967 onwards, which is when Harold Wilson devalued the pound, governments had been constantly in trouble and everything had been bad for Britain. And I think at the end of the 1970s, you started to get this sense that people were thirsting for some good news. So the first sign of that, I think, was the reaction to the SAS's raid on the Iranian embassy, which they liberated from a siege in 1980. And you have this almost hysterical reaction from the tabloids and so on, that Britain is great again, we're a top nation, all of this kind of stuff. And then you see it again twice in 1981. Once is the royal wedding, when we lead the world in pomp and pageantry. And the other time is this incredibly hysterical
的反应（不，三场，我们赢了三场，我们赢了三场，是的），但正是海丁利板球赛点燃了这种反应，这是一场惊天大逆转。关于这一点，有趣的是：博瑟姆作为当之无愧的英雄，他曾担任英格兰队队长，曾是一个极具青春朝气的人物、一个勇往直前的雄狮，所有人对他的期望极高。他被任命为队长，结果作为队长却一场未赢，创下了当时板球史上所有测试赛队长中最糟糕的纪录，然后他被解除队长职务。在他被解职的那天，头条新闻旁边并排刊登的是骚乱的画面。这两个是主要的故事，而它们其实基本上是同一个故事。那个故事就是：英国
reaction to winning one test match no three we won three we won three yes but it's the hellingley test that that sparks the reaction so it's the comeback and i think the funny thing about it is so botham who is the hero of the hour he had been the england captain he'd been this incredibly sort of youthful figure this sort of raging lion who's carrying all before him who's appointed in a captain then he then he doesn't win a match as captain he has the worst record of any test captain at that point in history and he's sacked from the captaincy and the day that he's sacked from the captaincy the headlines are juxtaposed with the images of rioting so they're the two main stories and they're both basically the same story and that story is britain
曾经很伟大，但现在它烂透了，它正在把自己撕裂，它赢不了板球比赛，它的城市在燃烧，一切都是灾难。然后，博瑟姆——偏偏是博瑟姆这个保守派工人阶级英格兰的化身——通过这场非凡的、如海格力斯般的壮举，扭转了局面，不是吗？新闻界简直欣喜若狂。我们又是一流大国了。然后就在几周后，迎来了皇家婚礼。当然，这一切为之奠定基础的，我认为，
has been great but now it's rubbish it's tearing itself apart it can't win cricket matches its cities are in flames all is sort of disaster and then both them of all people the sort of incarnation of conservative working-class england turns it around doesn't he in this extraordinary sort of herculean feat. And the press are beside themselves. We are top nation again. Then just a couple of weeks later, you have the royal wedding. And of course, what that all lays the foundation for, I think,
就是你在马岛战争中看到的那种民粹主义爱国主义。所以这基本上是在为你一年后马岛战争爆发时将会发生的事情埋下伏笔（这些都是预兆）。这些就是你所说的撒切尔主义的元素，是撒切尔对特定受众的全国性感召（博瑟姆至今仍是这种感召的化身）。嗯，人们常说职业板球运动员协会（即职业板球运动员的工会），
is the sort of populist patriotism that you get with the Falklands. So it's basically laying, you know, these are all omens of what is to come a year later when the Falklands War happens. And these are elements of what you'd call Thatcherism, of Thatcher's sort of, you know, nationwide appeal to a particular audience, which Botham still incarnates. Well, it's often said of the Players' Association, which is the trades union of professional cricketers,
它是唯一一个比其雇主还要右翼的工会。而且，我的意思是，博瑟姆成了撒切尔主义的英格兰——注意是英格兰，而不是英国——走向胜利的某种象征。他是一个热爱打猎、射击、钓鱼的人，后来他成了一名脱欧派，现在他也在上议院了。好吧，关于他最有趣的一点在于，他既有前瞻性，又具有怀旧色彩。所以
that it's the only trades union that's more right-wing than its employers. And, I mean, Botham becomes a kind of emblem for the triumph of Thatcherite, well, England, really, rather than Britain, Thatcherite England. He's a hunting, shooting, fishing man, and in due course he becomes a Brexiteer, and he's now in the House of Lords. Well, what's so interesting about him, right, is that he's forward-looking and backward-looking. So
如果你把1981年的伊安·博瑟姆拿出来看，你可以向前看，说这是脱欧以及所有那些事情的预演。或者你也可以向后看，说他基本上——他是什么？一个18世纪的人物？你可以想象他站在“胜利号”战舰的甲板上（老英格兰的烤牛肉）。
if you take Ian Botham in 1981, you can sort of look forward and say Brexit and all of that kind of stuff. Or you can look back and you can say he's basically, what is he, an 18th century figure? You know, you can imagine him on the deck of HMS Victory. You know, the roast beef of old England.
我的意思是，他的绰号“Beefy”（健壮、充满牛肉味）简直不能再18世纪了。当时还有一个非常尴尬的阶段，他去了洛杉矶试图成为詹姆斯·邦德，我想我们还是对这一幕合上帷幕吧。但博瑟姆身上还有另一个方面，它与种族骚乱有着有趣的联系。那就是博瑟姆与维夫·理查兹（Viv Richards）——西印度群岛最伟大的击球手之一、他那个时代最伟大的击球手——是好朋友。博瑟姆总是略微生活在他的阴影之下。有趣的是，另一个有点展望2020年的事情是，
I mean, his very nickname, Beefy, could not be more 18th century. And there was a very embarrassing stage where he went to L.A. to try and become James Bond, which I think will draw a curtain over that. But there is also another aspect to Botham which ties in interestingly with particularly the race riots. Is that Botham was great friends with Viv Richards, the, probably the, the, the, the great West Indies batsman, the greatest batsman of his day. Um, Botham was always slightly in his shadow. Uh, and interesting, another thing kind of, you know, looking forward to 2020 is that
西印度群岛和英格兰队争夺的奖杯以前被称为“威斯登奖杯”（Wisden Trophy），现在改名为“维夫·理查兹-伊安·博瑟姆奖杯”（Viv Richards Ian Botham Trophy）。所以在某种意义上，他也正展望着一个种族关系不像1981年那样具有爆发性的未来。是的，这是一个非常有趣的观点。我认为他和维夫·理查兹关系那么好的一个原因，是他们都是局外人。博瑟姆深深地感受到了自己作为局外人的身份，
the, uh, the trophy that West Indies and England compete for had been called the wisdom trophy is now the, the, um, the Viv Richards Ian Botham trophy. So there is also a sense in which he's looking forward to a future in which race relations will be less explosive than they were in 1981. Yeah, that's a really interesting point. And I think one reason that he got on so well with Viv Richards was they were both outsiders. And Botham felt very keenly his outsider status
在这个被白人公立学校男生主导的游戏中，所以他与维夫·理查兹建立起了深厚的纽带，不是吗？我记得他曾戴着牙买加色彩的手腕带，以此来表达对理查兹的支持。是的，这非常有趣，因为你看到了这种几乎是黑白联合的局外人联盟，共同对抗老卫道士、那些博瑟姆和理查兹觉得在主导这项运动的上流社会精英（Toffs）。好的，所以这正是历史学家会做的事情：挑选出一个图腾式的人物，并梳理出他的各个方面，然后或许可以将其反馈到更广泛的背景中。这样做合理吗？我的意思是，如果我们看皇家婚礼、看板球、看音乐，
in a game dominated by white public school boys so he he sort of he bonded with Viv Richards didn't he I think he wore the Jamaican colours in a kind of wristband to show his solidarity with with Richards yeah and that's really interesting because you have this sort of almost like black and white alliance of the outsiders against the old guard the Toffs that Botham and Richards felt were dominating the game. Okay, and so that's the kind of thing that a historian would do, is to pick up on a totemic figure like that and tease out aspects of him that perhaps you can then feed back into the broader context. Is that a fair thing to do? I mean, if we're looking at the Royal Wedding, we're looking
这能告诉我们关于撒切尔政府工会政策的什么信息？回答我这个问题。好吧，你给我出了个难题。嗯，我的回答是，撒切尔的工会政策之所以成功，是因为大多数普通的工会成员普遍赞同那些零敲碎打的政策……所以她通过的每一项具体改革，个别的工会成员都是赞同的。那些零敲碎打的政策……所以她通过的每一项具体改革，个别的工会成员都是赞同的。他们的领导人或许不同意，但她显然吸引了那种抱有宏大志向、渴望进步的工人阶级，你知道的，也就是那些技术熟练、受人尊敬的群体。
at the cricket, we're looking at the music, What does that tell us about trade union policy of the Thatcher government? Answer me that. Okay, you've sent me a challenge here. Well, I mean, my answer to that would be that Thatcher's trade union policy succeeded because most ordinary trade unionists generally agreed with the piecemeal bits of the... So each individual reform that she passed, individual trade unionists agreed with. piecemeal bits of the... So each individual reform that she passed, individual trade unionists agreed with. Their leaders didn't agree with them, but she obviously appealed to a kind of aspirational, working-class, you know, sort of skilled, respectable,
在板球比赛中，我们在听音乐，这能告诉我们关于撒切尔政府工会政策的什么信息？回答我。好吧，你这里给我出了个难题。嗯，我的回答是，撒切尔的工会政策之所以成功，是因为大多数普通工会成员普遍赞同她那些零敲碎打的政策……也就是说，她通过的每一项具体改革，普通工会成员都是赞同的。他们的领导人虽然不同意，但她显然迎合了一种渴望进步的、工薪阶层的、你知道的、那种有技能的、受人尊敬的阶层，
upwardly mobile working-class people, particularly in England. So your classic kind of Essex man. Now, Ian Botham's not an Essex man, but there are definitely parallels. And there's a kind of working class conservatism that Thatcher's union policy reaches out to, which is, you know, your union is actually, she says, your union is holding you back. Your collective loyalty is holding you back. You should think of yourself as an individual and get on and fight for a better life. That's what Ian Botham's about, isn't it? Right. And so opinions on, moving on from Botham,
向上流动的工人阶级，特别是英格兰的工人阶级。也就是那种典型的埃塞克斯人。现在，伊恩·博瑟姆不是埃塞克斯人，但两者绝对有相似之处。撒切尔的工会政策所触及的，正是一种工人阶级的保守主义。那就是，正如她所说，你的工会实际上正在拖累你。你的集体忠诚正在拖累你。你应该把自己当成一个独立的个体，去奋斗，去争取更好的生活。这就是伊恩·博瑟姆所代表的，对吧？没错。那么，关于……从博瑟姆的话题继续，
I mean, actually opinions on Botham, but opinions on the Thatcher government and perhaps Mrs Thatcher particularly, it's a subject of history, but it still remains very, very intensely a matter of politics as well. Your opinion of what Mrs Thatcher did will define you politically today in 2020. That's absolutely right, Tom. You know, in a sense, you know, like the French Revolution, it's too early to tell. Well, I don't know about it's too early to tell. I'll tell you what a story I was when I first decided I was going to write these series of books about modern Britain. A friend of mine who's now professor of history at Leeds, he said to me, are you going to do the 80s?
我的意思是，实际上关于博瑟姆的看法，以及关于撒切尔政府尤其是撒切尔夫人的看法，这不仅是一个历史课题，而且现在、过去以及未来很长一段时间里，依然是一个非常、非常激烈的政治问题。今天，也就是2020年，你对撒切尔夫人所作所为的看法将在政治上定义你是谁。完全正确，汤姆。你知道，从某种意义上说，就像法国大革命一样，现在下结论还为时过早。好吧，我不知道是不是为时过早。我来告诉你我当时的一个故事，当我第一次决定要写这套关于现代英国的系列丛书时，我的一个朋友，他现在是利兹大学的历史学教授，他问我，你打算写80年代吗？
And I said, oh, yeah, I have to. And he said, what are you going to do, Thatcher? I said, yeah, yeah, well, and he just kind of laughed and quite a sort of mocking way. And he said, everybody will really hate you, you know. And I said, why? He said, well, because I know you, you'll try to find, you know. And I said, why? He said, well, because I know you. You're trying to find, you know, you'll see both sides. You'll try to be balanced and all this. You can't be balanced about Thatcher. People just want you to hate her.
我说，哦，对啊，我必须写。他说，那你打算写什么，撒切尔？我说，对啊，对啊，嗯，然后他就笑了起来，笑得有点嘲讽。他说，每个人都会真的很恨你的，你知道的。我说，为什么？他说，嗯，因为我了解你，你会试着去寻找，你知道的。我说，为什么？他说，嗯，因为我了解你。你会试图去寻找，你知道的，你会看到双方的观点。你会试着保持平衡之类的。你对撒切尔是无法保持平衡的。人们只想让你恨她。
And of course, there's some truth in that. And my way of dealing with that partly was to say, of Thatcher, you know, in some ways, she's the last sort of great man. We talked about greatness in the first episode. Great man, great woman, sort of historiographical subject left. So people base their attitude to thatcher is they think she changed britain either for good or ill and and one of my big arguments is actually you know is that really true or is she really reflecting changes that are driven from below as it were you know if she died in 1978 would britain have been very different my argument is that it wouldn't that what happened actually
当然，这其中有几分道理。我处理这个问题的方式之一，部分就是对撒切尔说，你知道，在某些方面，她是最后一个所谓的“伟大人物”。我们在第一集里讨论过伟大。历史学意义上留下的伟大人物、伟大女性已经不多了。所以人们对撒切尔的态度是基于他们认为她让英国变得更好还是更坏，而我的主要论点之一其实是，你知道，这真的是真的吗？还是她其实只是反映了自下而上的变革？你知道，如果她在1978年去世，英国会有很大的不同吗？我的观点是不会的，发生的事情其实……
happened you know she was a symptom of the change rather than the cause My argument is that it wouldn't. That what happened actually happened, you know, she was a symptom of the change rather than the cause of it. So actually it doesn't matter whether you think she was brilliant or terrible. Because one of the arguments about what's happening at the moment with COVID and the way that it's affecting the North of England
发生的事情，你知道，她是变革的症状，而不是变革的原因。我的观点是，它不会不同。发生的事情就是会发生，你知道，她只是变革的表征，而不是变革的根源。所以实际上，无论你认为她是英明神武还是糟糕透顶，这都不重要。因为关于目前新冠疫情以及它对英格兰北部的影响比对南部严重得多的情况，有一种观点认为，这反映了某种根深蒂固的趋势，而撒切尔夫人则为此承担了责任。比如重工业、采矿业等的毁灭。你认为，我的意思是，我们能把80年代发生的事情的脉络追踪到新冠疫情的感染率上吗？还是说这仍然是一种政治判断，而不是历史判断？我认为这实际上是一个政治判断，汤姆，我有两点
much worse than the South is that this reflects kind of deep, deep, deep rooted trends for which Mrs. Thatcher is held responsible. The kind of the destruction of heavy industry, mining and so on. Do you think that there is, I mean, can we trace the threads of what happened in the 80s through to the incidence rates of infection and COVID? Or does that remain a kind of political rather than historical judgment I think that is a political judgment actually Tom and I two things
对此我有两点看法。首先，早在那个时期之前很久，南北之间就出现了巨大的分歧。我的意思是，我知道你是丹·杰克逊那本书《诺森布里亚人》的超级粉丝，是的，真的，你看过那样的书，它真的生动地展现了英格兰北部的体验与南部的体验在几百年里有多么不同。你知道，他们不是，他们是两个国家，早在玛格丽特·撒切尔成为奥尔德曼·罗伯茨眼中的一丝微光之前就是这样。所以你的观点基本上是马克思主义的观点，即这些都是根深蒂固的问题，你知道，这些是历史的巨大巨浪，而像撒切尔夫人这样的人只是浪尖上的泡沫。这完全是我的立场，汤姆，我给你举个例子。
occurred to me about that one is first of all there's been a big divergence between north and south right long before that I mean I know you're a big fan of that book by Dan Jackson the Northumbrians yes and that really I mean you look at books like that that really brings alive just how different the north the experience in the north of England felt for hundreds of years from the experience in the south. You know, they're not, they were two nations, as it were, long before Margaret Thatcher had been a glint in Alderman Roberts's eye. And so your perspective is basically the Marxist one, that these are deep-rooted issues, that, you know, these are the great surging waves of history, and that someone like Mrs Thatcher is just the kind of the foam on the crest of the wave. That is exactly my position, Tom, and I'll give you an example of
你谈到了重工业的消亡。难道有人认真地认为，如果没有玛格丽特·撒切尔，你知道，成千上万甚至数十万人每天早晨还会下井去挖煤吗？我的意思是，所有的重工业在其他每一个欧洲国家都消亡了，几乎是每一个欧洲国家。所以认为这一切都是玛格丽特·撒切尔的错，而且事情本可以发生……我的意思是，它可能发生得更慢一些。它可能发生得没那么具有争议性。它可能发生得，你知道，事情的结局可能会有所不同，但基本的故事仍然是一样的。所以从这个意义上说，是的，这有点像马克思主义的历史，对吧？巨大的力量等等。我不知道……嗯，撒切尔夫人是否会
that. You talked about the death of heavy industry. Does anybody seriously think that without Margaret Thatcher, you know, tens if not hundreds of thousands of people would every morning be going down pits to dig for coal. I mean, all that heavy industry has died in every other Europe, virtually every other European country. So the idea that it's all Margaret Thatcher's fault and it would happen, I mean, it might have happened more slowly. It might have happened less contentiously. It might have happened, you know, things might have worked out differently, but the basic story would still have been the same so in that sense yes that is kind of marxist history isn't it great big forces and all the rest of it i wonder whether um mrs satcher will
继续保持这种恶魔般的地位，或者（根据你站在辩论的哪一边）英雄的地位？因为我记得去年还是前年，BBC上有一部关于撒切尔夫人的非常优秀的系列片。我很高兴你提到这个，汤姆，因为我就是那个系列片的顾问。好吧，我觉得，多米尼克，这真的很棒。而且我想它根本没有任何解说，对吧？它只是一种……没有主持人，没有解说，是的。
continue to hold this kind of demonic status or you know status of heroine depending on which side of the debate you stand because i i remember there was some, was it last year, maybe the year before, there was a really excellent series on the BBC about Mrs Thatcher. I'm so glad you mentioned that, Tom, because I was the consultant for that series. Okay, well, it was, I thought, Dominic, well, it was really excellent. And I think it didn't have any commentary at all, did it? It was just kind of... No, no presenter, no commentary, yeah.
只有当代影像资料和受访者。我和我女儿一起看了那部片子，她当时大概，我不知道，16岁左右，对这个主题一无所知。她的看法非常符合一个年轻女权主义者的视角。是的。她看到的是一个女性在这些沙文主义老古董面前取得胜利。这就是她的看法。是的，我觉得那个故事，那方面，肯定会显现出来。你知道，人们会看到她是一个被男人包围的职场女性，而这是他们以前没有看到的。你知道，20年以前，
Contemporary footage and interviewees. And I watched that with my daughter, who must have been, I don't know, 16 at the time or something, knew nothing about the subject at all. And her take on it was very much that of a kind of young feminist. Yeah. That she was watching a woman triumphing over these kind of chauvinist dinosaurs. And that was her take. Yeah, I think that story, that side of it, will definitely come out. You know, people will see her as a working woman surrounded by men in a way that they didn't. You know, 20 years ago,
他们没有看到玛格丽特·撒切尔女性的一面。或者更确切地说，他们会说，她根本算不上一个女人，现在可没人会这么说了。我能看出来，就在我说话的时候，制作人一直在给我发短信，说她不喜欢女人，她不为女性维权诸如此类的话。但从这方面来说，实际上，玛格丽特·撒切尔是她那种类型女性的典型代表。当时人们常谈论“女王蜂”，指那些在60年代和70年代出人头地却不肯提携后辈女性的女性。
they didn't see the femininity of Margaret Thatcher. Or indeed, they said, she's not really a woman at all, which nobody really would say now. I can see that even as I'm speaking, the producer is throwing texts at me to say she didn't like women, she didn't champion women and all this kind of thing. But in that respect, actually, Margaret Thatcher was typical of women of her type. People used to talk at the time about queen bees, about women who had got ahead in the 60s and 70s and then didn't pull up other women after them.
从心理学角度来看，其实你可以理解为什么有些女性会表现成那样。她们和玛格丽特·撒切尔的想法一样，觉得：我是凭自己的能力出人头地的。凭什么让我，你知道，为其他女性设立平权行动？她们应该像我一样努力工作。在那些最早出人头地的女性——也就是那类职业女性——与后来者之间，一直存在着这种张力。
And psychologically, actually, you can sort of understand why some women behave like that. They thought, like Margaret Thatcher thought, well, I've got ahead on my own merits. Why should I, you know, institute affirmative action for other women? They should work just like I've worked. And there was always this tension between those women who'd been the first ones to get ahead, the kind of professional women,
但你是对的。我认为人们会……年轻人，我的意思是年轻人根本不在乎，对吧？在10年或20年后，他们会在乎马岛战争和矿工罢工吗？不过我认为，我认为，我认为我女儿对那个故事的反应——在完全不了解更广泛政治背景的情况下——其实是因为那个故事本身有一种神话般的弧光，一个默默无闻的女性最终脱颖而出并成为首相的故事，
and then those who came after them. But you're right. I think people will younger people i mean younger people won't care will they in 10 or 20 years time will they care about the falklands and the miners strike well but i think i think i think that what what my daughter's response to just to this that story having no sense of the broader politics of it was that there was a again a kind of mythic arc to the story of the woman who emerges from nowhere and and and becomes prime minister which
这再次将她与戴安娜联系在了一起。有趣的是，我们确实有这两个具有神话色彩的人物，而且她们都是80年代的女性，我想《王冠》这部剧就会借题发挥，这正是该剧的卖点所在，对吧？这个系列正是靠这些来吸引眼球的，不是吗？但这也表明，历史如何被理解以及在某种程度上如何被消费的一个关键方面，就是作为神话。神话特质本身就具有历史意义。
again aligns her with diana and it's interesting that the two you know we do have these two kind of mythic figures and they're both women in the 80s and i guess that that's what the crown will be will be riffing off that's what it's all about isn't it this series is all trading on that that yeah business isn't it i mean but? But it does suggest that a crucial aspect of how history is understood and in a sense consumed is as myth. The mythic qualities are themselves of historic significance.
完全正确，汤姆。关于你说的“神话特质具有历史意义”，我觉得这很对，因为玛格丽特·撒切尔，我的意思是，她在受众眼中被消费的方式，要么是库伊拉·德维尔，要么是人们口中的……他们管她叫什么来着？芬奇利的叶卡捷琳娜大帝？是的。
That's absolutely right, Tom. And I think your, where you say the mythic qualities are of historic significance, that seems to me right too, because Margaret Thatcher, I mean, she was consumed, as it were, by the audience as a sort of, she's either Cruella de Vil, or she's the people, what do they call her, the Catherine the Great of Finchley? Yes.
或者她，你知道，她的崇拜者视她为布狄卡，为不列颠尼亚，为伊丽莎白一世。所以，这里确实存在着这样一种永恒的神话：那个被男人环绕的高贵女性、爱国女性，以及那个女巫。是的，还有那个女巫。你认为她扮演的是哪个角色，取决于你的政治立场，但人们总是把她放在这些神话般的角色中，不是吗？我的意思是，没有人会简单地说她和其他政治家一样，或者她和其他职场女性一样。人们谈论她几乎就像在谈论某种超自然的存在，你知道，嗯，把她放在和伊丽莎白一世、戴安娜或布狄卡同等的地位上，或者说戴安娜，因为戴安娜同样也让人们产生了对立的看法。
Or she's, you know, her admirers see her as buddhica as britannia as elizabeth the first yeah so there there is there are these there's this constant myth of the the regal woman of the patriotic woman surrounded by men and the witch yeah and the witch and she which part you think she plays depends on your politics but people always put her into these sort of mythic roles don't they i mean nobody just says she's a politician like any other she's a working woman like any other they talk about her almost as this superhuman you know um on the same level that they talk about elizabeth the first or or or diana or booty well or diana because like diana likewise was similarly divided people.
你知道，她是人民心中的王妃，还是说她，你知道，戏剧化且缺乏骨气？同样，全国在这个问题上也是分裂的。不过，我们对男性好像就不会这样。不，不。我的意思是，也许亨利八世会，但没几个人。没几个男性会让我们用这种二元对立的方式去谈论。是的。我觉得我们没话可聊了。
You know, was she the queen of people's hearts or was she, you know, histrionic and lacking backbone? And again, the country was kind of divided on that. We don't really do that with men, though. No, no. I mean, maybe Henry VIII, but not many. There aren't many men that we talk about in the same sort of dualistic way. Yeah. We've run out of things to talk about, I think.
我想是的，我们已经……我们把整个80年代都聊透了吗？你知道这里面还有多少内容吗？我们没聊托尼·本。我们没聊鲍比·桑兹，肯·利文斯顿。但这只是意味着我们几个月后得再做一期专门聊1981年的播客。哦，我跟你说，你还没提到的是，呃，杜兰杜兰乐队（Duran Duran）和西蒙·勒·邦（Simon Le Bon），以及我对你在整本关于撒切尔时期的书中，最喜欢的一句名言。出自那整整7,000页的内容。其实，因为我为了这个做过功课，我把它找出来了。呃，而且，
I think we have we have we have we have we exhausted the whole of the whole of the of the 80s? Do you know what's on this so much? We didn't talk about Tony Benn. We didn't talk about Bobby Sands, Ken Livingstone. But that just means we'll have to have another podcast all about 1981 in a few months time. Oh, I tell you what you haven't, what you haven't mentioned is, is, uh, Duran Duran and Simon Le Bon and the, the, the, the, my favourite quote, um, in your entire book on, on the Thatcher period. From all 7,000 pages. Which actually, because I was swatting for this, I've, I've got it here. Um, and, um And this is with reference to Union of the Snake and Hungry Like the Wolf. Simon Le Bon said, I've always liked poets like T.S. Eliot,
这是在提到《Union of the Snake》和《Hungry Like the Wolf》时说的。西蒙·勒·邦说：“我一直很喜欢像T.S.艾略特这样的诗人，他们有点晦涩难懂。这绝对是我歌词风格的一部分。”所以你看。《荒原》本可以成为……《Planet Earth》和《荒原》。这就对了。《普鲁弗洛克之歌》和《Union of the Snake》，是的。所以这真的是一档能够触及其他播客触及不到的领域的播客。
who are a little bit obscure. And that's definitely part of my style, lyrically. So there you go. The Wasteland could have been a... Planet Earth and the Wasteland. There we go. Proof Rock and Unionnew the Snake, yes. So this really is the podcast that reaches the parts that other parts don't.
我们每周都应该引用一次杜兰杜兰乐队的歌词，你不觉得吗，汤姆？这绝对是个挑战。然后我们可以接着聊斯潘道芭蕾舞乐队（Spandau Ballet）……对，没错，新浪漫主义乐队。我们会尝试每周引用一句新浪漫主义乐队的歌词，那将是一个有趣的挑战。
We should have a Duran Duran reference every week, don't you think, Tom? Certainly a challenge. Then we can move on to Spandau Ballet and... Yeah, well, yes, a new Romantics. We'll try and quote a new romantics lyric every every week that would be an interesting challenge
说到每周，我想这一周就到此为止了。我们下周还会回来。多米尼克，你还有什么要补充的吗？
and talking of every week I think it's time to close off for this week we'll be back next week Dom do you have
有很多，但我们没时间了，所以我大概只能作罢，不过希望大家都听得高兴。我们以后每周一都会更新，对吧？周一早上，汤姆。是的，周一早上，对，这就是计划。所以请大家订阅、评分并写评论，不过最好……当然只留好评啦，是的。是的，请把那些差评直接发给汤姆。呃，如果有什么问题、想法、意见，欢迎积极投稿。邮箱是therestishistorypod@gmail.com。the rest is history pod at gmail.com。这就是联系我们的方式，你也可以在推特上给我们发私信。
anything else to add lots but we don't have time so I'll probably have to just forego it but I hope you've all enjoyed it and we're going to
我们下周再见。再见。再见。感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。想要收听独家番外、抢先体验、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
be out every Monday aren't we Monday morning Tom yeah Monday morning yeah that's the plan so please do subscribe and rate and review but only well only reviewed if it's a positive review obviously yes yeah just send those negative reviews um directly to tom um and uh and any questions, any thoughts, any comments, do contribute. The rest is historypod at gmail.com. Rest is historypod at gmail.com. That's how to contact us or you can message us on Twitter.
我们每周一都会更新，对吧？周一早上，汤姆。是的，周一早上，对，这就是计划。所以请大家订阅、评分并写评论，不过——嗯，只有在是好评的情况下才写评论，当然。是的，是的，把那些差评直接发给汤姆吧，嗯，还有任何问题、想法、评论，欢迎踊跃留言。TherestisHistorypod@gmail.com。RestisHistorypod@gmail.com。这就是联系我们的方式，或者你也可以在推特上给我们发消息。
And we will be back next week. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们下周再见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如需收听独家节目、提前收听、无广告收听并加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。